Before I used Kiro,
I was very stuck in the details of syntax and
oh,
I've got to switch to this programming language for this code repo.
How,
how do I
do a variable or,
you know,
something pretty basic
and Quiro can
do it for me.
We now have a way to understand and interact with and define
our code,
our business,
our.
Requirements in ways that we never did before.
Gone are the days of spending hours debugging,
looking for a tiny hidden semicolon.
Kira helps me through the entire process.
I started coding in my early teens,
and the first time I wrote a piece of code and I was able to successfully run it,
it gave me a lot of joy,
and I feel that Quiro brings back that spark.
Going down.
The ordinary routes of just building code from scratch
would have taken us weeks,
but with Quiro,
we were able to,
in the space of 3 days,
go from zero to hero.
It is a partner I have with me throughout the entire process.
I ask it questions,
I start the development with it.
I create specs with it,
and I learn while using Quiro.
I've been working on trying to add some new features to this large system.
It is helping me from start to finish with ideation,
from actually coming up with requirements,
tasks,
and
execution.
Have
my idea be reality without
the most mundane part of it was just,
you know,
the typing of the keystrokes.
And it gives me a different perspective and enables me to do whatever comes to mind,
honestly.
I'm Kyra's biggest fan,
I'm pretty sure.
Please welcome to the stage vice president
of Developer agents and experiences at AWS
Deepak Singh.
Good morning.
Thank you for joining me today.
So,
my name is Deepak,
and I run the Developer Agents and Experiences Organization at AWS.
So,
as you've seen,
as you just saw,
and as you've probably heard throughout this conference,
it is an incredibly exciting time to be a developer
and to be working with artificial intelligence.
Over the last few years,
we've witnessed a major transformation
in how
software is being built.
We've gone from
simple
autocompletion using a coding assistant.
To sophisticated AI agents that can write complete applications,
multi-file applications
in one go.
They can reason,
they can help you plan,
they can implement your software,
and usually all you need
is simple natural language prompts
or a diagram or two.
So refactoring projects which used to take
days now get done in hours.
Debugging sessions can be done in a few minutes.
I just saw an example there.
and
projects that used to take months can get done in weeks,
and features that used to take weeks can now be done over a single weekend.
And I actually talked about a couple.
We are quickly shifting
to a world where agentic AI not only allows us to write code faster,
it's actually a collaborative assistant.
You work with the agent.
You,
it,
it helps you achieve a different kind of flow state.
You get to continue working,
but now you almost have this second assistant sitting with you,
a powerful brain
that helps you move so much faster.
This is a brain that helps
learns from every line of code it sees.
It recognizes patterns and opportunities for improvement.
It gets smarter with every interaction.
Every commit
and every deployment.
And this is what today's agents give us.
You could call them superpowers that enable new ways of delivering software.
They significantly
accelerate innovation.
We are seeing this every day,
both on Amazon and with our customers,
especially in a world where speed and differentiation
are absolutely key.
This transformation has been quite remarkable,
and
yet it still feels like it's the early days.
As I look back,
I'm kind of reminded of August 2006.
Show of hands,
who remembers what happened in August 2006?
No,
that's when EC2 was launched.
Uh,
EC2 came out in August 2006 in beta.
I was not an Amazon at the time.
I was a bioinformatician
at a bioinformatics company,
and I already had an S3 account and I set it up a few months earlier when S3 had come up,
and I launched my first EC2 instance.
Great.
And a few days after that,
there was an evening
where I,
on a whim,
fired up 22,
20 EC2 instances,
which is the limit you got at the time.
And
ran a protein secondary structure algorithm,
a simple feed single layer feed forward neural network
to predict the secondary structure of a bunch of protein sequences just
because I wanted to.
That felt absolutely magical.
It made me feel empowered in ways that I had never felt before,
and less than 2 years later,
I joined AWS because that was so amazing.
The kind of empowerment is what
we feel,
what I see builders around me experiencing.
Every day,
and it's the kind of empowerment that you get
as a software developer once,
maybe 15 to 20 years.
Being a developer is
an extraordinary role.
You get to build meaningful solutions.
You push technological boundaries.
You leverage cutting edge cloud technologies to
create exceptional software to help customers,
but it's also quite challenging.
You would love
to keep building features for everybody you know to
do things that
spark your innovation,
your passion,
your fulfillment,
but you also often get stuck in tedious,
mundane activities.
They're not bad,
they're important,
but you have to do them.
At AWS our mission is to empower developers
by harnessing the power of AI
and what we want to do is
eliminate the friction
between vision and execution.
We want you to create at the speed of thought.
We want you to achieve breakthroughs that were once unimaginable,
or
you're constantly putting aside because you're busy with other things.
The developer landscape is evolving rapidly,
and our goal is to help you navigate this transformation.
For a very,
very long time,
the only way you could build was by handling
most of the work yourself.
Some of you remember when
you had to write every line of code,
you had to debug issues,
you had to update documentation,
you had to manage your dependencies,
and then you had to work through deployments.
Today,
AI agents in two ways.
They help you spend your time effectively on things that matter.
They either offload the tedious tasks.
You have a bunch of things that you need to get done,
but you're busy with something else,
you can give those to the AI,
or
you can collaborate with the AI,
as I said earlier,
and accelerate the things that you really,
really care about.
So
the things that you want to pay attention to yourself,
in the end you get to focus on what matters to you,
ideally what's bringing innovative ideas to life.
This rise of human agent collaboration has revealed some
super important patterns over the last few years.
We started
with AI just generating chunks of code,
sometimes initially just a line,
a line or two at a time,
to multiple lines to multiple files,
and today
you can collaborate
with agents and humans and actually
you're increasingly agents collaborating with agents
on larger and more complex tasks.
So
your role is to give the agent the right context.
The right set of tools,
the right input,
and provide that human judgment and guidance that only you can.
And developers need these AI capabilities embedded
throughout their workflow
from initial planning
all the way through testing and deployment.
Perhaps the most crucial insight that we've had
was that to truly transform software development,
it's not just about having access to an agent.
You need to think about how AI is going to get
embedded from the beginning all the way to the end.
So not just with coding,
but also how you shape your architectural decisions,
how you identify edge cases,
how you maintain best practices throughout your flow,
and
these lessons
are inspiring,
and we get them from watching teams.
Where we work,
watching our customers,
they help
inspire how we think about the future of what developer tools are.
They are shaping our vision for building
integrated AI solutions and integrated AI development experiences.
This is not a future trend.
It's happening right now.
6 months ago it felt like the future,
but 6 months in the world of AI and agents is
almost like 6 years.
The most successful developers are already embracing it.
I like to say they're jumping into
the Olympic pool without a life preserver and saying we're going to figure this out,
and they do.
We've actually noticed something super interesting
as we talked to these developers.
Some developers are seeing 1015,
20% productivity as they start using these tools.
Others are achieving 5 times,
10 times more
productivity improvements.
They're using the same tools.
So what's the difference?
The difference is that it's becoming
increasingly clear.
It isn't just about using an AI tool.
It's just a tool.
It's how you use the tool,
how you're helping yourself move faster,
and it's
You get there by fundamentally changing how we approach software development.
The most successful software developers,
and we get to see them in action often,
are rethinking their entire process,
rethinking how their teams think about the process of software development,
and they're using AI agents as collaborators
and constantly working with them
to achieve these kind,
these crazy results that we are seeing.
It's a mindset shift,
but that's what you need to get that level of improvement.
I talked about EC2.
Cloud computing transformed how we think about infrastructure.
You no longer had to think about how you rack and stack
hardware.
Agentic AI is freeing us from this code first
development.
It's not a bad thing to
think code first,
but it's changing how code is developed,
um.
I'm a musician in my free time,
a terrible one,
but there's this piece of software called Ableton Live.
For those of you who've used it.
It has a nonlinear way of developing which
takes you away from the standard left to right
tape track way of
building software music that all the other software used to do.
And this game,
and it completely revolutionized software and music and how music is made.
AI agents are doing the same thing with software.
We are working towards a world.
Very,
very rapidly
when natural language intent
or an image
or a diagram
or pseudocode,
that intent becomes working software.
It is a world where tools that we need to build software look
quite different.
I like to think that what you need is not a code editor,
but a more conversational context management system,
something that helps you drive and write down
what the agent needs,
drive its behavior
to get to the place you want to go to.
Uh,
you're almost
spending more time supervising,
managing,
and reviewing the work of AI agents
than you are typing on a keyboard to
with,
with
some
coding programming language.
The other way to think about this is
just the early coding assistants were just tools.
Agents are not mere tools.
You can refactor an entire code base and manage
multi file changes.
Your role as a developer
is no longer just typing.
You're orchestrating these agents,
and that.
It's not something that happens right away.
You have to learn.
Agents,
the craft of software engineering
is evolving.
Software engineering is a craft
you
learn it by doing it.
Yes,
there are college courses,
school courses.
They'll teach it to you.
You'll learn a language,
but to become a really good developer,
you have to do it for a long period of time.
And we are seeing a lot of people learn this,
relearn this craft,
take what they have learned as software developers,
as systems thinkers,
and apply it to agentic software development.
It's a change in the calculus of how software is built.
So think about it,
your team size,
how the team is structured,
your development velocity,
how you think about technical debt.
All of these things are going to get reshaped
over the coming months,
I'm not even saying years,
and,
and it,
it'll get reshaped because you're going to build software differently.
It's going to change because we approach our
teams and how they approach building software differently,
and
it changes how we think about what's possible or
if I paraphrase Matt Garman from two days ago,
why not?
So let me illustrate what this shift means in practice,
as I said.
On the,
you know,
a few seconds ago,
software developers are craftspeople.
If you want to take it to an extreme,
a lot of folks take
pride in meticulously writing every line of code,
how their code is structured,
what it looks like on screen,
how they orchestrate these tools and manage every aspect of the development
themselves.
But there is a
challenge that comes with it.
Sometimes in,
as you write code,
as you're building your software,
some of the critical decisions,
strategic,
architectural,
business,
often come later down and you
have to go back and make some costly changes.
This AI agentic paradigm kind of flips this on its head.
As a developer,
you can front load a lot of these
high value strategic architectural and business decisions
and the discussions you may have with your design team or your product team,
and then you work with the AI agent
to explore what the implications could be.
You can work through trade-offs really quickly because
you can build prototypes really fast.
You can do it even before any code is written,
but you can also write a quick application to just get your mental model right,
to make sure that you're thinking straight.
And,
and part of this is all the execution is being handled by the agent itself.
It is not just that you've taken the level of abstraction higher,
because
you know in the world of software that's every few years
you try and come up with a new layer of abstraction.
It's about enabling developers to think through the entire system
holistically
to ensure that there are implementation details aligned with what your vision was.
How do you take what's in your head
and convert it into a running application that's going
to be maintainable for a period of time.
And what we've seen and what we observe
is these rich technical conversations,
these conversations about why you,
why you're even doing what you want to do,
they happen up front.
And
then the goal becomes how you drive the agent to get you to where you want it to be,
and that's where you get these 5x,
10x develop productivity gains.
It doesn't.
It's not just about how we write changing how we write code.
It's how we write software,
and
developers can go,
you can join it at any point you want.
You can start by writing a concept.
Your product manager or your designer can come up with
a concept and bring it to you with the prototype,
and then your job becomes how do you convert that into a working solution
with the help of your friendly neighborhood agent.
And instead of,
you know,
you can get,
even in AWS where historically we've developed features using
product press releases and FAQs,
very often the way a new piece of software is
built is somebody goes off for a few hours,
maybe the product manager,
maybe a developer,
maybe your dev manager who hasn't previously hadn't coded for a few years,
and they quickly come up with a specification,
a design,
a prototype,
and then all of you can review it and say,
yep,
we know we can build this in the next couple of days.
We see this happening all the time.
This is
quite a shift.
It's not easy.
It's not a technical change.
You are,
in the end,
you're still building software.
It's the how you build that software,
how you organize to build that software,
what you get comfortable with.
All of that changes,
and you get unprecedented speed from idea to implementation,
and you'll see a few examples of this today.
This flow of AI coding workflows is kind of awesome.
You can get going really quickly.
I can,
I've stopped counting the number of applications I've built just to show my son
an example of some scientific thing like how the solar system works or
Maxwell's equations.
Don't ask me why,
but as these tasks become more complex and ambiguous,
You,
the,
how you interact with an agent only takes so far.
Um,
you need to start thinking at the systems level.
Uh,
very often,
systems thinking happens only when you are a senior engineer.
I would argue that
as a junior engineer you need to start
thinking about it less from the
from the side of I'm writing a particular piece of software,
I'm writing code
to how's my system going to work,
why am I even building this,
what are the components it needs to have,
and then you work with the agent to get to where you want to.
You're no longer thinking about the nitty gritty of
the actual coding process itself,
and that's
for some people that's a huge change.
We've also found,
especially
over the last 6 to 9 months,
that
When people started using AI agents,
they got pretty comfortable with it.
They'd start talking to it,
or vibing,
as they called it.
That word,
we live in the techT generation.
I think vibing has almost gone out of fashion.
I don't know why it came up,
disappeared,
uh,
but it also became increasingly clear.
My favorite example is you build an app and 10 days later you have no idea why the
app is doing what you did,
what did,
what prompts you had written,
and if you hand it to somebody else,
you completely lose all context.
So you needed constant oversight
from design decisions.
You were writing it down to documentation and testing.
And the question we asked ourselves was,
is there a more structured framework that we could
use to make this whole process a lot easier,
to bring out,
are there any artifacts that can help
you remember
six months from now,
or if you hand it off to a different team,
why you did what you did
so they can continue going from there
and not just looking at the code
and
Well,
how could we bring the lessons from very mature software engineering practices
to build maintainable software
using AI?
And Takiro
That's why we built it
and why we built what we call spec driven development.
The idea with Quiro
is to help developers and teams do their best work
by bringing
Mature software engineering practices
to AI-driven coding
with
the idea of spec-driven development and the concept of spec-driven development.
So
what is it?
So the way it does it is you want
to go from idea
to a functioning application,
but you
also know that application is going to evolve from there.
It may go on to another team.
You may add components to it.
You may be part of a company that requires enterprise grid controls.
We wanted all of those things,
whether you're an individual developer
all the way to a team of a very large team at a big enterprise,
or to be able to use these concepts
and be able to build
using AI.
So
The way Quiro works is you can start off with a simple set of prompts.
You can convert these prompts into a
clear set of requirements and structured designs.
You can start your prompts don't have to be natural language.
They can be an image.
They can be a diagram.
They can be pseudocode.
What's in your head,
how you express them.
It can be done by a product manager.
It can be done by a designer.
It can be done by a software developer.
Quiro then works with you to convert these specifications into working code,
into working documentation,
into working tests.
You have a feature called Agent hooks.
It's a feature we don't talk about that much,
but it's one of the most useful features of Quiro.
Agent hooks automate routine tasks in the background,
and what you can use agent hooks for
is to enforce development best practices automatically.
And
Quiro is fundamentally multimodal.
You have smart context management
that helps you continue to work
the way you want to.
And your access to frontier models like Clotssonnet 4.5,
Opus 4.5,
so you can pick and choose.
You might want quality,
speed,
cost,
all of those are factors that you as a developer
get to think about.
So what happens at the end,
you get the familiarity and fun
of what we used to call white coding.
You can
just
talk to your agent.
You can get going really quickly,
but
you have much more powerful,
maintainable
code and a developer experience that helps you get there.
So you can tackle any project regardless of its size or complexity.
This spec driven
approach struck a chord with a whole bunch of developers.
When we launched Quiro in preview just in the 1st 5 days,
we got over 100,000 developers,
and since then,
hundreds of thousands of developers outside of Amazon have continued to use Quiro.
And,
and
you know you've seen some great examples throughout this conference.
What makes spectrumn development so useful and powerful?
Uh,
one of the artifacts
that Quiro builds with a prompt is a requirements doc.
It's in Es notation.
For those of you who are familiar with EEAS,
it's a markdown-based,
structured way of writing down a set of requirements.
Quiro can then extract properties from those requirements,
and this is why I love specs.
And then
from these properties it can determine which ones need to be logically tested,
and it generates hundreds of thousands of random test cases
to check your code.
It helps you figure out whether this intent that you had
expressed
with a set of prompts that got converted into a spec
is the application and the code that comes out at the end
actually doing what you wanted.
So
let's take,
let's look at an example.
Let's say you're building a car sales app.
You may want,
you know,
your traditional unit test approach would be
user adds car number 5 to favorites,
car number 5 appears in a list,
and you would do a unit test for that.
You may do a few more unit tests
with this property-based testing approach.
The way Quiro works is
for any,
you know,
it writes a requirement which will be something
like for any user and any car listing.
That when the car
gets added to favorites,
display the car in the favorites list.
That's how it'll get converted into ears.
With some specific language that ES supports,
and then
what Quiro will do will extract
a set of tests and build them for you,
things like
user A adds car number 1,
user B adds car number 500,
user C adds 5 cars,
uh,
user D.
Has special characters in their username.
You may have cards with various statuses,
you,
you know,
new,
used,
you know,
pre-certified,
all of that,
hundreds and thousands of more combinations that help you catch these edge cases.
These are generated automatically.
These are tested automatically,
and what you are doing is you're verifying that the what the code and
software that comes out at the end matches the intent in your head.
This is remarkably powerful,
and it's just the first step
towards software verification.
If you saw Swami's keynote yesterday,
I think it was yesterday,
reinvent just flies by.
You heard Byron Cook on stage talk about neurosymbolic AI.
You can,
because you have structure in a spec,
you can start applying neurosymbolic techniques
which will help you make sure
that your code is doing what you wanted,
and that's how you build trust
in AI agents.
That's how you can move
at the speed of light.
So,
Developers are finicky.
Some people like IDs.
Some people.
Like the terminal.
Uh,
so while we spent,
we've spent a lot of our time talking about Quiro as an IDE.
We want to,
you could put this agent in a terminal as well for those
of you who sit in a shell and troubleshoot and write software,
that's a very natural place to be.
It's,
um,
so that's what you get with Quiro CLI.
You get the power of Quiro agents in your favorite terminal.
You can put it in any one.
you use them in a couple.
The Quiro CLI carries over your context,
your steering files,
and MCP configurations from the IDE.
It helps you shift with precision from prompt to deployment in your terminal.
And you get the simplicity and elegance of the terminal,
and I assure you it's not a light saber,
although I wish it was.
Um,
so anyway,
terminals
are
an environment that some of the most successful
developers that I have worked with using AI
like to use,
and Quiro CLI gives them the power to get there.
Kiro CLI uses the information across your entire code base.
It helps you build features in complex code bases.
You can automate workflows in seconds,
analyze errors,
trace bugs,
adjust fixes,
and
what you're doing in the terminal is driving this highly interactive loop
at the back.
There's an agent.
The keyro agent happens to be written
in strands,
so you drive this agentic loop,
and the CLI is just a very
easy place to do it.
And since you are in a CLI,
you can use automation scripts.
You can automate all of this.
You can automate shell commands that invoke the CLI with the right context
to automatically execute prompts.
So if you want to troubleshoot a production failure
or generate and publish pull requests,
and when your task requires you to get back in the flow,
you can jump right back into your terminal,
and Q Kiro will adapt to your feedback in real time.
It also helps you paralyze agentic tasks really quickly.
Because you have 5 problems,
10 problems,
you can just send
a bunch of agents to try and solve those.
You can also manage projects using something called custom agents.
You can create an agent
that is tailored to a specific task,
so you can put a set of your custom prompts,
your context files,
tool permissions all together
and create a custom agent,
for example,
one that loves doing backend coding,
while another custom agent can do front-end work.
And this is where some of this parallelization can get really cool.
You can run 3 of these in parallel one doing front-end work,
one doing back-end work,
and 1 may be doing some other
helper tasks
that go and solve some other problem.
And these
custom agents allow Quiro to become an expert in a specific area.
They don't require any reputation.
They don't risk context degradation.
And
you can work at any scale.
You could be doing just simple bash commands or some really complex workflow
or running 20 of these agents in parallel all night.
So
it's lightning fast and super powerful.
Las Vegas is really dry.
I've been talking for too long,
so it's time to see all of this in action.
I'm sure all of you want to.
And who better to show you
than Brooke Jamison.
Welcome,
Brooke.
Thank you.
I've built this serverless e-commerce store on AWS.
We've got Dynamo DB,
Lambda,
API Gateway,
the works.
But right now it's just placeholder products.
I have real product photos and descriptions for the
Quiro merch I want to put in the store,
and I need to get this production ready.
Hero works however you work.
In the IDE or in the terminal,
let me show you both.
First,
I'll use Vive in the IDE to visualize the architecture.
Kiro is reading my infrastructure files and using the AWS
diagram's MCP server to generate the cloud architecture diagram.
We've got lambda functions,
Dynamo DB,
S3,
and cloud front.
Now,
I need some product descriptions.
I put some vague descriptions of things and a style guide in this repo.
Kiro is now reading my style guide,
checking the available photos,
and generating on-brand product descriptions for my store.
Now it's time to optimize those product images,
and some of you prefer the terminal,
so here's Kiro CLI.
Similar capabilities,
different interface.
I'll ask it to resize all my product photos for the website.
Keep the proportions,
make the grid consistent,
optimized for fast loading.
Hero's created a note script with Sharp,
installing dependencies,
processing 38 images to WebP at 2 sizes,
full resolution and thumbnails.
Same intelligent assistance,
just in your terminal.
Now we're done and all images are optimized.
Now for the complex work,
replacing all those praise holder products with actual merch.
This touches the backend data layer,
seed script,
and front-end components.
For structured development like this,
I'll switch to Opus 4.5 and use spec mode in the IDE.
I'll tell it what I need.
Put my actual products in the store.
I've got photos and descriptions ready.
Let's get ready for production.
Spec mode starts by generating requirements,
and it's breaking down what needs to happen.
Updating the backend to handle multiple product images,
modifying those screen scripts to use my real data,
and updating front-end components for the new product structure.
Now it's creating the technical design.
Here's what makes spec mode powerful.
It defines eight correctness properties,
not just does it work,
but formal properties like for any product configuration,
the seed script produces identical results,
or all S3 objects must have correct metadata headers.
Each of these becomes a property-based test later on.
Now,
the implementation plan.
We have 10 tasks broken into subtasks.
Each task maps back to the requirements and design.
I'm making
all tasks required so we can build this comprehensively.
Let's watch it work and starting with task one.
This is creating the product configuration file.
Spec mode reads my product descriptions,
maps the image parts from the optimized images folder,
sets the pricing,
validates everything,
and creates the JSON config.
Task complete,
so now onto task two.
This updates the data access layer to handle multiple images per product,
and here's the key part,
it writes a property-based test.
This test doesn't just check one product,
it validates that all required fields are present
across 100 randomly generated scenarios with different IDs,
categories,
and data structures.
Now,
I'll jump ahead to show you something important.
Task 9,
the final verification.
Task 9 writes two critical property-based tests.
Property 7 tests seed reproducibility.
It validates that if I reset the database and reseed it,
I get identical results every time.
Property 8 tests configuration-driven pricing.
It verifies that when I change prices in my config file,
those changes are reflected correctly in the seeded products.
These aren't just testing one scenario.
Each property test runs 100 iterations with randomly generated data.
That's 200 test cases just in this task
validating that our system behaves correctly under all conditions.
By the end,
we have 8 property-based tests covering everything.
And now all tasks are complete,
all tests are passing.
Here's the live store,
we've got real products,
new categories and optimized images,
multiple images with thumbnail validation.
But wait.
This image is a bit cut-off,
so let's go back to Vibe for a quick fix.
Hero analyses the screenshot I pasted in,
finds the component,
identifies the issue which was some wrong CSS
and some bullet points that needed passing.
Now,
it's fixed,
so work however you work.
Vibe in the IDE for exploration and quick fixes.
CLI if you live in a terminal,
and spec mode for structured development with property-based testing.
From architecture diagram to production ready store,
that's Kiro.
Back to you,
Deepak.
Please.
Thanks,
Brooke.
I wanted to share
a remarkable story.
You've probably heard it a few times this week,
but I'm going to share it again anyway,
of how one of our AWS teams completely transformed the development process
using Kiro CLI.
So when Anthony Liguri,
who's a distinguished engineer at AWS,
was,
he was asked to rebuild the inference engine for Amazon Bedrock,
and the initial estimates were that it would take a team of say 30 developers,
12 to 18 months
to go build this very critical component of bedrock.
The team
knew that
12 to 18 months
was not
going to be
quick enough.
They wanted to do it much,
much faster.
And
they also knew that adding more developers is not going to help them at all,
that there's a law of diminishing returns,
so they wanted to think about a different way to go solve this problem,
and
they did that,
and they did that.
They wanted to do that without
compromising the quality or reliability of the system
because this is such a critical component.
And so they went to KOCLI to assist with their development.
And
the results were absolutely remarkable.
A team of just 6 people was able to deliver in 76 days
what had originally been estimated to take 30 people 12 to 18 months.
The individual productivity for developers jumped 20x on that team.
Your weekly code comments,
they started off,
you know,
when,
when you're doing a traditional approach,
where 2 check-ins per developer went to
over 40
check-ins per developer.
On average,
there were some folks on the team doing even more.
And
it wasn't just about the numbers,
the way they were collaborating,
the way they were building,
the techniques that they built
were,
were fabulous,
and
they all had fun doing it.
The,
the
job satisfaction ratings on the team
were
were exceptional because they could use their AI
to handle routine tasks,
and the developers worked with
Quiro CLI
to solve the most intricate and hard and strategic problems that they had,
but.
It didn't happen overnight.
Initially they used it the way a lot of people use AI agents,
very discreet tasks.
Just,
you know,
working with an agent,
giving it some work to do,
seeing what happened,
coming back to it.
The real breakthrough came
when they fundamentally redesigned the workflow built around
the AI capabilities as opposed to bringing
the AI capabilities into the existing workflows.
So they discovered
three critical patterns.
That would result in this exponential improvement.
The first one was
they moved from task to task supervision to goal-driven direction.
Their job was to give
the agent the goals
that they wanted to accomplish
and then providing all the supporting information,
your steering files,
assistance,
you know,
what they should be doing,
providing better prompts to make sure that the agent was able to do it.
Then they scaled out to a number of concurrent AI tasks to increase velocity.
I talked about custom agents earlier.
They were unleashing swarms of custom agents
often overnight
to go solve these problems,
and when they came back in the morning,
they would then go and review the changes that had happened.
And finally
they were able to extend this AI beyond coding
to every aspect of what they did,
from how they talked to each,
how they worked with each other,
how they collaborated,
to every part of the software delivery process.
And that is what allowed them to achieve the
level of productivity that we were talking about.
They went from cautious experimentation
and
started seeing massive gains,
and this is something that we've seen not just with this team,
but with many other teams that have learned these lessons.
So as they mastered those patterns,
the development velocity basically went from,
you know,
somewhat
more than 10 to 15%
we had talked,
talked about earlier
to the 5x,
10x,
20x that this team is getting right now.
You've heard me say this a few times now.
You only get those levels of gains if you change the way you
build around the agents as opposed to applying the agents and getting them to
Add to the work that you're already doing today.
Even small teams can dramatically outperform traditional approaches,
so your developers can do a lot more.
They can actually do things they may have been putting aside for the last 10 years
because it'll just take a week and they don't have the time.
Now you can go ahead and do it,
and you see examples of that every day.
The Quiro demonstrates what's possible when
developers have access to powerful agents,
but even with this foundation,
agents don't automatically know how to use every tool out there.
They don't know how to use every tool correctly.
You don't know how to exactly work with an MCP server,
for example,
where they are translating a design to implementation,
handling some security pattern,
managing a deployment,
making them less effective without constant human guidance.
These are all lessons you have to learn.
So we started asking ourselves,
How can we help?
What can we do?
How can we capture these knowledge and best
practices that are often scattered across people,
documentation,
uh,
wikis,
a blog post somewhere,
or YouTube video somewhere?
So it makes it difficult for AI agents to
access the relevant information to get the right context.
MCP
provides connectivity to development tools,
but there's additional configuration required.
You often have to write really good steering files.
You have to write hooks
so that you can get the right level and quality of code at the end,
otherwise you'll have to refactor like crazy.
So developers need their agents to work with the tools they use every day.
And we started thinking about how we could help,
how we can make these tool connections really work for them without
overloading context.
And you know,
so rather than leaving developers to figure out the right context,
you know,
through trial and error,
we came up with this idea
of Quiro Powers.
And what we've done is come up with a system that you can build your own powers,
but we also worked with a bunch of top technology providers
and tool creators to
build the first version of Quiro Powers which launched yesterday.
You can start using it right away.
They extend sort of the core purpose of Quiro
by enabling developers to bring structure to AI,
which is what we started off with.
But now you can give the Quiro agents specialized capabilities or powers on demand
as you need it across the entire software stack.
So what is the power?
It is a package set.
Of artifacts in this particular case created by a set of tool vendors,
but you can also create your own artifacts
MCP servers,
steering files,
and hooks.
They're bundled usually around a specific domain such as backend development or UI
or
observability or API design.
And we've also done it in a way
that instead of relying on generic agents and overloading with documentation,
we dynamically load the context and exact tool access,
so the way you go through your credits and tokens are also a lot more efficient.
This is available inside the IDE right now.
It'll come into the CLI soon,
and we are working on ways to make it available to any ID or CLI that you may be using.
You don't have to use just Quiro
with Quiro powers.
So each power is designed in collaboration with a set of domain and tool providers.
Here
you have a set of names.
It also includes,
uh,
which is Hashi Corp,
and these are for,
you know,
areas like UI design with Figma,
backend deployment,
development with Superbase.
You can
have a power for Stripe.
You can build a full application
all the way
using these powers,
um.
You can customize each power to match your organization's requirements.
You can actually go in and
make modifications.
You can stack multiple powers together to create sort of enhanced capabilities.
For example,
you can use the stripe power with the data dog power or DynaTrace
to build a new payments application
with observability on performance and security.
You can create and share new powers with other people,
and
Uh,
just looking at Twitter since yesterday,
we've,
I've already seen people creating a bunch of powers that they can use
and they're sharing with the rest of the community.
Let's see this in action.
So we're going to use the kito power from DataDog.
To set up telemetry on a front-end application for real-time
user monitoring,
so ROM as they call it.
Once this power has been installed,
we're going to activate the power in a new session.
And
once we are up and running,
you're going to ask Quiro to add client-site logic to our application
in order to start tracking these rum metrics.
So in my setup,
I also need to provide an environment,
uh,
that to set up,
to provide a set of environmental variables to my application.
Once this is configured,
DataDog will generate events whenever somebody clicks on a
button or adds new products to the cart.
But guess what?
We are starting to see some errors popping up.
OK,
that's what DataDog is supposed to show you.
You check them out
and you see that the add to cart
page is causing an error.
So you want to quickly resolve this issue.
So you ask Kiro to fetch these rum events that
have errors and ask Kiro to suggest a fix,
and Quiro will review the errors,
determine that the errors are due to the due to a required host name configuration
for external images.
It'll apply the fix,
resolve the issue with the add to cart page,
and
Voila.
You have the new,
you have the,
you have a fixed page
with
using the keto power.
We are actually using Quiro to build Quiro.
We do that.
We've been doing that from day one.
Quiro Paws is one example.
All of Quiro Powers was built
using specs
by the Quiro team.
From,
you know,
core capabilities like system notifications,
error handling were all developed purely through specs,
often in less than a week.
One example
from very recently
is how we use Quiro to build its own caching system.
We built a specialized analysis tool
using Quiro that reduced triage time from 2 hours to a couple of minutes.
Most importantly,
because we built this caching system,
our reduction in,
we had a 72% reduction in infrastructure costs,
and all of this was done over a weekend.
This kind of rapid,
sort of purpose-built solution development represents the
power of spectrum and development in action.
And
building Qiro with Quiro was a way for us to learn how we could get
insights into what the transformation could be,
and we'll continue to add capabilities like
Quiro powers that help the Quiro agent
be that much more effective for the things
you want to do.
These lessons are super important.
AI agents are changing at a rapid pace.
New models come out.
New science comes out.
They increasingly grow more powerful because you can do more reasoning.
You can handle significantly more complex work autonomously
because of better context windows and better tool handling,
and
agents
are constantly analyzing code.
They're optimizing performance.
They're flagging issues.
You saw this example of the parallel execution that the
Bedrock team was doing.
But
they're also actively collaborating with
developers in real time.
So
you have this fluidity of AI agents.
You're
working,
you start off your day by working with an agent
in front of a terminal
or in front of an IDE,
and you start assigning tasks to the AI in
the background while you work with the AI tasks
on the things that you want to do.
And the background task could be anything from security
scanning and dependency updates to architecture and implementation.
We wanted to capture
some of these practices in
which a lot of developers are starting to learn by hand and implementing
as products
within Quiro.
So earlier this week we introduced 3 new frontier agents that represent
in our,
in our belief,
a major leap forward in AI power development.
So what is a frontier agent?
There are a new class of AI agents that
are offered by AWS.
They have a few defining traits.
One,
they're autonomous.
You direct them towards a goal,
and they figure out how to achieve it without you having to constantly prompt it.
They need to be able to figure out
what they even need to go do.
They're massively scalable.
We've talked about scalability being one of the
key lessons that the Bedrock team learned.
How can we make that kind of capability available to everybody?
The autonomous agents allow you to do that.
They're able to perform multiple concurrent tasks
and distribute work across agents automatically,
and they work independently,
sometimes for hours to days
without intervention.
That is a key capability.
I'm going to mostly talk about the Kro
Autonomous agent because that's for software development.
It helps you ship more product more quickly,
focus on the highest value tasks,
so you can assign
all your refactoring tasks and your P3 tasks to it.
The security agent is an application security
agent that's constantly scanning your code.
It's also doing penetration testing.
The DevOps agent does incident response.
It prevents future incidents,
and it's again constantly scanning your code
in case you have new lessons that you need to apply
to existing applications to make sure you are running,
operating safely.
So
With these frontier agents you're no longer just
being collaborative with a developer always sitting.
You can deliver complete outcomes.
You can add them as extensions to your team.
You're going to operate in a way again,
this is a new way of working
where you are basically saying there's this,
there's a team,
there's a teammate that you have that can help you
as a team move much faster or as an individual.
So let's dive deeper into the key autonomous agent.
So this agent works with developers and with teams.
It autonomously handles development work.
So
one of the first things it does
is it's constantly running.
It's running all the time,
building a comprehensive
understanding of your code base and patterns,
and it learns from your code reviews to improve with every task.
So every interaction
you have with the autonomous agent
makes it smarter,
makes it more capable.
So
you know,
typically with an AI assistant,
including the ones that we've talked about today,
you're actively managing context,
and
you know that's the learning,
that's the craft that you have to learn.
You have to constantly re-explain your preference or pattern.
You have to build a system to show,
to share context across repositories,
and they're almost always session-based.
Once you close a session,
the agent forgets about everything,
and next time you start a session,
it needs to remember.
Kiro Autonomous agent is not session-based.
It's always available.
It maintains context across all your work.
It's sort of running alongside you and your team workflows,
so it constantly maintains context
and automates development tasks,
so you don't have to stop and slow down to tell it something.
It's constantly going.
It can tackle a full range of activities,
so you can use it to develop new features.
You can use it to triage bugs to improve your code coverage,
and all of this happens in the background.
You,
you know,
you point it to your issue backlog
and give it some tasks,
so you keep doing what you need to do,
and the autonomous agent will
do what you asked it to do in the background.
It connects to tools you already use Jira,
GitHub,
Slack
in the team's version,
GitHub in the individual version
to build a shared understanding of your work.
So if you're part of a team,
it's actually learning from Slack.
It's learning
from your GitHub interactions.
It's learning from your backlog.
And
one of the coolest thing is,
and I think this is
probably my favorite part of autonomous agents.
On day 30 it's going to be more effective than it was on day 1.
On day 60,
it's going to be more effective than it was on day
30 because it continues to deepen its understanding of your code,
your products,
and the standards
your team follows.
So let's see it in action.
So
you saw the Quiro Swag store.
It's grown,
and you want a simple way to save your favorite items.
So if you want to add a wish list experience.
So on GitHub,
all you need to do
is add the Quiro label
to
to your issue and hand this off.
And the moment you do that,
it hands it off to Quiro,
and the agent takes over.
It immediately creates the task,
pulls the entire issue context,
and starts preparing a sandbox.
Everything you do runs in the sandbox,
and after a quick analysis,
it proposes a clear plan
and a breakdown of this task.
It already,
you don't have to tell it anything.
It already understands how this change should thread
through the stack because it's built that understanding.
And then the agent will go and validate the plan.
It'll analyze the repo.
It'll make sure there's enough context to proceed,
otherwise they'll ask you for help.
It then explores the project.
It maps the back end,
maps the front end.
It looks through your handlers.
It looks through your API config,
your data model,
and it aligns itself with the approach that,
you know,
it knows how the system was built,
so it's going to align its approach to the way the system was built,
and it runs the change end to end.
It updates data access for the wish list.
It hooks it into the product page.
It keeps the UI and backend logic consistent
with the patterns that you're already using.
It runs tests,
validates behavior.
Checks type safety.
It ensures the agent integrates properly and cleanly,
and then
you get a clean pull request.
You get a diff
and a clear summary of what changed.
And since the agent is not session-based,
it doesn't forget.
So when you give it feedback on one pull request,
it'll automatically apply the
learning to the next 10.
So back in the store,
you have your wish list.
Users can now tap the heart.
You can save your favorite item,
and we track how many people love each product
and
You can go
even faster.
You can parallellyze all of this.
In fact,
the agent itself will figure out how to paralyze all of it,
each with its own context.
So let's say you're implementing a new wish list feature.
Kiro can also go fix a bug over here that you found last night
or solve another,
you know,
do a refactoring over here.
All of this,
we believe,
is the next phase of AI development,
increasing the velocity and scope of work that can get done by an individual
or a team.
I've had the,
you know,
we've seen how customers have been using
AI assistance over the last couple of years.
Um,
they've gone from pilot to production,
discovering ways that AI can fundamentally change how their teams work
across the entire development life cycle.
And one of the people I've,
we've been lucky to see this with is Brittany Doncaster,
who's the chief architect at Delta,
and she's here to share their transformation story.
Welcome,
Brittany.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Deepak.
I'm so excited to be here and I'm even more excited to share with
you all Delta's journey and incorporating G
Gen AI into our software development practices.
We all know
that Gen AI is transforming how we build
and how we deliver software,
and we all want to do it faster.
At Delta,
we
delight in
our customers experiencing delight,
and we want to build software that delights our customers.
And so we've been on a journey
to do that
quicker using Gen AI.
But introducing
coding assistants
just isn't enough.
And if we look at why that is.
Everybody's been focusing on just developers
and
giving developers coding assistance and Gen AI coding tools
and agentic coding tools and all these things,
but at the end of the day,
developers are only one piece of the puzzle,
and a lot of developers across the industry only spend about
30% of their time
actually developing.
And so if you optimize that 30%,
that's great,
but you're not gonna see end to end improvements across the life cycle.
And so we've started looking beyond the tools to our processes.
And here at Delta,
we have taken a dual path approach.
On the first path,
we're taking our existing product development life cycle or our PDLC as we call it,
and we're infusing AI into that
PDLC process.
We're trying to do that in a way that makes it natural for folks
across the activities that they already do today.
And so we want to do that with as little change as possible
and really just smoothing out the transitions,
helping them have better data when they're making decisions,
and trying to automate the processes that exist today.
But then,
we know that's only gonna get us so far.
To really get that next level of speed.
We're gonna take that PDLC
and we're gonna chuck it out the window
and we're gonna reimagine what a PDLC could look like
given the tools that we have at our disposal today
given Quiro
that we've been utilizing from AWS and Quiro CLI
and we're gonna look and see
what happens
when we forget what we think we know
about product delivery.
The reason we've done that is because
change is hard for an enterprise
and change management's difficult.
And so
we know that we've got to introduce change.
In a really methodical way.
So let's dig a bit deeper into the first path and talk about
how we started introducing the change into
the existing product development life cycle.
The first thing we knew we had to do
was that we had to get adoption up
and we knew we weren't gonna see any changes or any
difference if we didn't have people actually utilizing the tools.
So we focused on adoption.
We held launch events,
we held workshops,
and we went in just a little over 4 months,
from 6% of our user base
to over 12020%.
Now for those of you who are sitting there going,
her math is not mathing.
How do you get over 100% of your users?
I will tell you.
You get over 100% of your users
by originally anticipating that only developers are going to utilize the tool.
Because that's what we thought when we roll out a tool called Q Developer,
you kind of think that only developers are gonna be the ones utilizing it.
But as we started to do these trainings
and workshops and all of the enablement sessions,
what we ended up seeing was that our technical product owners,
our business analysts,
all the people surrounding the developers
actually wanted access to QCLI too.
They also wanted to use it
in
their process.
in support of building software
and so we actually ended up partnering with AWS
and bifurcating the training
and we created a
specific non-developer training with AWS that we could give our non-developers
so that they could utilize the same tool that our developers were utilizing.
Because
at the end of the day,
QCLI and Quiro,
a lot of it is about the context.
And when you're giving the people around the developers
the same context that the developers have,
you end up unlocking some,
some additional savings and
improvements.
But we quickly had to pivot from adoption to impact.
So
once we started seeing we have people,
not just
we have these users,
but they're actively using it daily,
weekly using
this tool.
We started to look at what the impact of the tool was
on our metrics.
Like every other company,
we have a ton of different metrics for developer productivity,
and one of those is cycle time,
but we break that cycle time down into
development time and delivery time.
And we define development time
as branch creation to branch merge,
and delivery time is branch merge to code and production.
And what we ended up seeing
was as Q and QCLI adoption increased and became
daily and weekly usage across our developer landscape,
we saw our development time go down.
But what we didn't see was our delivery time go down,
and we didn't see our deployment frequency go up.
And so we could see through our data and our metrics
that we were coding faster,
but we weren't delivering faster.
And so we knew we had to go beyond development.
And so that's what we did.
First we went to the right of development,
and we started looking specifically at delivery
time because we could tell from our metrics
that that was our bottleneck.
That was where we needed to
invest and to optimize.
And so we looked at how could we use
QCLI
to optimize and automate the processes that exist there.
How could we utilize it to improve our test automation,
our integration tests,
improve some of the things that are
just those paper cuts that hurt and make developers wanna say,
you know what,
instead of delivering each of these code changes,
I'm just gonna batch them up
because the process is kind of
maybe not as optimal as it could be
and so we started working on ways to make that more optimal
at the same time.
We listened to our developers and we heard
that sometimes when they were getting features and stories
from their product owners
it wasn't articulated as well as it might could have been
or it wasn't as clear to them what they wanted out of it
and so we started.
Using these tools in order to help us standardize
what is included in a feature in a story
and what's articulated in those
and then also to help drive more clarity so that there's less churn
going back and forth between the product owner
and engineering.
But in order to really change the game,
we know we have to go down our 2nd path.
And that is why
we have started
our 2nd path and our 2nd journey.
And the way we're approaching this is we are taking pilot workshops
and we are breaking down the walls
of the traditional teams that are part of product delivery.
We are bringing the product owner and the engineering
into a workshop
and we did this recently with one of our product owners and our senior developers
in um in one of our business units
and the feedback we got from that product owner
was that
it
took them
what normally would have taken them
probably a couple months to do.
It took them
a couple days,
really a little less,
a day and a half
in a workshop,
and when we start
looking at that kind of savings
and that kind of speed,
it really is transformational,
and you have to start to think about
a different kind of process,
a different kind of team structure,
what does product development look like in the future?
And we don't quite know yet,
but we know we're gonna keep experimenting,
we know we're gonna keep collaborating.
And we know that we're going to use Quiro
as the enabler for both of these.
So why does this matter?
For Delta,
we really want to deliver our products to our customers
as quickly as we can
and so we're taking
on the left hand side
what we know
it works today and making it more scalable and optimizing it,
but then we're also innovating.
And we're doing this so that we can bring you
the products you love
faster
and get more speed.
But this isn't just about technology.
This is about positioning Delta for long term success.
Our roadmap is clear.
We'll improve today,
we'll experiment for tomorrow.
And we'll scale what works.
Thank you.
I'll welcome Deepak back to the stage.
Thank you,
Brittany.
Delta is an amazing example of how quickly
agents can help a business grow and thrive.
It doesn't just help the developers build faster,
it helps the builder builders of Delta think
through entirely new ways of working across the development cycle,
and they'll continue to evolve.
What makes it possible is this ability of
humans and agents to work seamlessly together.
So where is all of this going to go?
We have seen examples of the possibilities,
but we've also seen some of the challenges.
Humans working with agents can ship code 10 times faster than maybe you can do today,
but that's only going to accelerate because of a couple of changes.
If we can orchestrate multiple agents working together
and redesign the software delivery processes that we have
from the ground up for a world where multi-agent systems are writing and operating
a good chunk of our software.
So
one of the questions we often ask ourselves is,
what is the value of code
in
as an artifact in a world where humans are working with agents
and agents are doing most of the code analysis and writing.
It is easy to imagine an expert
expert planning agent managing context precisely,
spinning up agents that implement features,
review and deploy code,
optimize performance and cost,
manage operations.
Humans in the loop will continue to be critical.
Humans provide the level of judgment and intent that nobody else can.
You are the only people who know what you want to build,
but what they do,
the processes they work within,
the tools they use,
the tools we all use,
are going to look
completely different
from what we do,
what we are doing today.
I believe an IDE will evolve into
a context management and agent orchestration system.
The SDLC is going to be much more iterative and rapid fire
than it is today.
And
as all of that happens,
we have many open questions.
How do we make and communicate decisions faster?
Humans are still involved.
How do we verify intent matches output?
How do we make sure that the output
is verifiable?
How do we build that trust?
How do we reduce the blast radius
of all of these changes,
because things will continue to break.
The solution looks more like conducting an orchestra
and less like playing an individual instrument,
or if you're like me,
a good band.
You still need to understand what good music sounds like,
uh,
and as a band you're responsible for the overall output,
but you don't have to play each individual instrument yourself.
And this transformation is not theoretical.
It is happening right now.
You have seen examples of this throughout this conference.
Over the next 12 months,
it's going to dramatically evolve,
and we are committed to being your partner
throughout this evolution.
Thriving in this rapidly changing environment requires more than just tools.
It requires support,
it requires continuous learning activities.
And learning is just not about formal training,
it's about community and connections.
Learn from the people in this room.
Learn from the people you see in other talks who are actually doing what
are practicing what they're talking,
people like Brittany and Delta.
And that's why we've built one of the
technology's most vibrant and supportive developer ecosystems.
And in the case of Quiro,
we have a
Discord community with more than 14,000 developers,
including of developers of
all backgrounds and skill sets.
You can also join a local group within Discord.
Ask questions,
exchange ideas,
learn about best practices through local community-led gatherings,
and I encourage you to join the AWS community,
the Quiro community,
join a local user group,
connect with community builders,
discover new ways to learn,
grow,
and innovate together,
and.
Over the last hour,
I hope we've shown you that we are the dawn of something extraordinary.
It's not something
to be afraid of,
it's something to embrace.
The possibilities that we have explored aren't incremental.
They represent a fundamental shift
in how all of us are going to imagine,
create,
and deploy software,
and we're going to be with you throughout this journey.
We're going to provide the technology,
the resources,
and the support,
and I'm really excited about the future that's unfolding
and what we'll achieve together.
So.
To help you get started,
we're offering every reinvent attendee 1000 kiro credits.
And for the startups in this audience,
we're giving away up to 1 year's worth of Quiro Pro tier,
Kiro Pro Plus tier,
up to 100 seats credits as well
through the end of the year.
You can go apply at kiro.gov.
And
thank you,
thank you for being here today.
I hope you're as excited about the future of software as I am,
and I can't wait to see you with Studio Bell.
Bye.